GUS CLASS: Hello, Google
Developers, and welcome to
this week's episode of "Google+
Developers Live."
Today we're going to be talking
about targeted sharing
on Android.
I'm Gus Class, a Developer
Programs Engineer for Google+.
And with me here
is Chirag Shah.
CHIRAG SHAH: I'm Chirag Shah,
and I'm a Software Engineer on
the Google+ Android SDK.
GUS CLASS: So, great.
So today we're going to
be talking again about
configuring and targeting
interactive posts on Android.
We'll also talk about how you
can think about targeting
these posts on Android.
So as I go through the code,
Chirag here, our Android
expert, will be giving us some
pointers on what's going on
behind the scenes and some
more information on
development with Android
for Google+.
So before we begin, Chirag.
Do you want to tell us a
little bit more about
interactive posts?
CHIRAG SHAH: So, interactive
posts brings users directly to
your Apple website with a
call-to-action button.
Clicking the call-to-action
button will bring recipients
to a specific place in
your app where they
can perform an action.
GUS CLASS: Awesome.
So before we get into the
code, let's start with
configuring the application from
the developer console.
So, on my screen you can see the
Google API's console open.
And what I'm going to
do is I'm going to
create a new project.
And then I'm going to give
this a meaningful name.
And just so that you know, this
is also documented on
developers.googl
e.com/plus/quickstart/android.
And so if you want to get
started on there, it's an easy
way to quickly get going with
developing on Android.
So all the steps that I'm
seeing here are also
documented on the web if you
want to follow along.
So after I have turned on the
Google+ service, then I'm
going to enable API access
by creating an
OAuth 2.0 client ID.
And again, you'll just have
to put in a meaningful
product name here.
And then after you've done that,
you're going to set up
an Android application.
So this is going to be an
installed application.
It's going to be installed
on the Android devices.
And so I'm going to click
Installed Application and then
click Android.
And there's two parameters
that I'm going to
have to fill out here.
The first is going to be the
package name, and so you just
put in the app name here
that you'll get from
your Android project.
And then the second is going to
be the signing certificate
fingerprint.
And creating this fingerprint,
you're going to use the key
tool which is a thing that
allows you to extract
information about your developer
certificate.
Chirag, do you want to talk a
little bit more about this
signing certificate?
CHIRAG SHAH: Yeah.
So what we're doing here is
identifying our Android
Project with Google, and
allowing our Android Project
to talk to these various
services.
What we're doing here is
extracting the SHA1 hash of
the signing certificate for
the debug certificate.
And that allows us to keep
developing before we go to
production.
Once we go to production,
we'll get a different
production key store
and extract the
certificate from there.
And generate the SHA1 hash from
there and register it
again with Google before
going to production.
GUS CLASS: Awesome.
So if we look at my screen
again, you can see that I've
loaded up my console and I've
got the command for exporting
this certificate.
And so what you would do is
after you run that command,
then you copy in this SHA1
hash, paste it into your
console, and then your project
is pretty much
set up at this point.
We're going to do one more thing
before continuing, and
that is we're going to
enable deep linking.
So when I click this reveal
button and then turn on deep
linking, it'll let me
use deep links from
within my Android app.
Chirag, can you give a little
bit more information on deep
linking and Android apps?
CHIRAG SHAH: Yeah.
So deep links allow users to
share the exact state of an
application on Google+.
When the pulse is viewed on a
mobile device, the user will
be directed to the exact state
that was shared on Google+.
If the user doesn't have the
app installed, they'll be
prompted to install it on
their mobile device.
Ready to start diving
into code, Gus?
GUS CLASS: Yeah.
Just one second, I'm going
to set up the project.
And so if you look at my screen,
you'll see that I have
set up an Android project that
has all been configured within
the API's console and
is ready to go.
And this is also the exact same
project that ships in the
Android SDK, so all this code
is pretty much already
available to you.
And what I've done is I've added
some functionality to
this sample app that we'll talk
about in just a minute,
but let's first look at
the plus share code.
So this is inside of
the share activity.
And within that share activity
is an intent that is returned
and used to render that
Share dialog.
And in order to set this up, the
first thing that we do is
that we use the PlusShare
Builder to construct a
PlusShare object.
And then we configure
parameters
from within that builder.
Chirag, can you give us some
more information about these
parameters as we look
through the code?
CHIRAG SHAH: Yeah.
So we use the PlusShare Builder
to create an intent to
the Google+ app to display
the Share dialog.
This builder helps us configure
the Share dialog to
display exactly what we want.
We use the Add call-to-action
button to configure the red
call-to-action button
in the Share dialog.
So here in the sample, we're
configuring the Share dialog
to display the view item
call-to-action.
We also configure what happens
once that button is clicked.
So we pass in a call-to-action
URL and a call-to-action
deep-link ID.
The call-to-action URL is used
on desktops and the deep-link
ID is consumed on
mobile devices.
Next, we set the content URL.
The content URL helps us define
what data gives context
to the user about which action
they're going to perform.
So in this case we're setting
the content URL to our
developer documentation.
And from there we've annotated
it with Schema.org markup,
which displays what description
should show up in
the Share dialog and also what
type of image should augment
and give more context
to the user.
GUS CLASS: So there's two sets
of links that we're really
talking about here.
So I'll get this started so we
can see what's going on, but
there's two sets
of links here.
The first set is the content
links, and then the second set
is going to be the
call-to-action links.
So want to differentiate
between these
a little bit, Chirag?
CHIRAG SHAH: So the content
URL is used around the
call-to-action, so it's placed
on top of it as you can see in
the Share dialog.
And once you click on it, it
points users to the particular
research that's being shared.
Whereas for the call-to-action
URLs, it basically guides the
user to perform a particular
action in that application.
And the deep-link IDs are used
for mobile clients to navigate
users to a particular use
resource that's being shared.
GUS CLASS: So if we look at my
screen again, we can see the
sample running on my phone.
So this is the same sample
that you know and love.
It ships with the SDK.
And this is as it would run just
as if you hadn't made any
changes yet.
So when I create the interactive
post and I click
Go, what you'll see is you'll
see the same thing that you
see on my screen.
You'll see the pre-filled
text that is from this
line of code here.
You'll see the content URL which
is going to be rendered
on this part of the screen
near the bottom.
And then you will see
this View Item
call-to-action button.
So if I'm correct, the
call-to-action links will
determine which content appears
inside of this button.
And then the content is what
appears inside of that little
rendered area on the bottom
of the screen.
CHIRAG SHAH: Exactly.
So the content URL gives a
little more information to the
user about what's being shared
and what type of action they
would be performing once
they click on the
call-to-action button.
GUS CLASS: Awesome.
Thanks, Chirag.
So I'm going to go look
at one more thing.
So if I click on who this post
is being shared with, the
little dialog box that appears
in the top of the post, I'll
notice that it's
set to public.
Now, where did that public
come from, Chirag?
CHIRAG SHAH: That's
a good question.
So that's actually the last
Share target specified in the
Google+ Share dialog.
So last time we shared
on Google+ and
filled out some people.
It'll get displayed again, but
we can do a little better with
interactive posts.
We can actually set a specific
set of people in the Share
dialog and actually get
targeted sharing.
So with the PlusShare Builder,
you can specify the method Set
Recipients, and from there you
can set the exact Share target
that your application wants.
GUS CLASS: Awesome.
So let's return to the code
here, and here is that
setRecipients method.
And what I'm going to do later
on in the code is I'm going to
create an array list of
recipients that I'm then going
to use for the Builder method
for setRecipients.
So I've cheated a little bit
here, and I've already written
a lot of the code.
But let's walk through the
important sets of the code so
that you can understand
what's going on here.
So when I turn on that Best
flag, what's going to happen
is, instead of just starting the
activity, what I'm going
to do is I'm going to call
this method loadPeople.
And what that is is this is an
implementation of an interface
that's specified by the
Google+ platform.
And so if you look at the very
top of my code, you can see
where I have copied and pasted
this onPeopleLoadedListener
from the listPeople activity.
And what that will do is when
that method is called, this
callback function for
onPeopleLoaded will be called,
and then inside of here
will be data.
Chirag, can you give some more
information on how these
pieces connect?
CHIRAG SHAH: Yeah.
So when you call Plus Client and
loadPeople, it's actually
an asynchronous call.
And Google Play Services will
go out to the network, fetch
the specific set of people as
determined by the network, and
return that back to your
application as specified by
your Callback interface.
So once the people have been
loaded, it'll specify a
passive person buffer into the
onPeopleLoaded handler.
And Person Buffer is actually
a cursor-like interface, and
once you're done loading the
specific people from the
buffer, you'll have
to close it as to
avoid any memory leaks.
GUS CLASS: OK, so we have this
person buffer, and then we can
take those objects and then we
can add them to this array
list of best recipients.
And then later, before we
retrieve this intent and then
we start the activity for
results, what will happen is
we'll have that list of people
already added into the data
that's set up by the
Share dialog.
So while this loads, do you
want to talk a little bit
about why you want to call
startActivityForResult?
CHIRAG SHAH: So when you call
startActivityForResult, it
gives attribution to your
calling package and helps
render the Share dialog
with attribution.
And you'll need to do
this for interactive
posts or it won't work.
GUS CLASS: OK, so
there you go.
Make sure that you call
startActivityForResult so that it works.
So let's run the same code that
we ran before now that we
set the recipients
for this post.
So if everything worked
correctly, what we'll see is
we'll see the list of
the best recipients.
This is something that's
worth mentioning.
When I performed that method
loadPeople, on the backside
it's doing a list of the people
using the Google+
Platform API.
And this allows you to sort by
alphabet, or it allows you to
sort by best.
And so I've done a sort by best,
and so the top five best
people that are associated with
my demo account here will
be returned to my app.
So if we look at the list here,
here's the five people
and this looks good.
Chirag's missing.
I don't know why, because he's
one of my best people.
But there's also something
else that's different.
You'll notice that that list of
recipients that we had set
before, Public is
no longer there.
Chirag, why is this happening?
CHIRAG SHAH: So back when we
called the setRecipients
method in the PlusShare Builder,
we set the specific
share target for this Share
dialog, and that actually
overrode the previous Share
target because our application
is specifying exactly who
should be shared with.
GUS CLASS: OK, so that's
it for today.
You've seen us taking an
interactive post and then
adding specific recipients to
it so that you can create a
much more contextually
useful and relevant
post for your users.
And next, what we've done is
we've set up that post and
then rendered it
to the stream.
And then when you set that
list of recipients, then
you're ready to go.
So it looks like we may
have some questions?
MALE SPEAKER: We do have a
couple questions, thanks, Gus.
So one question is
from Gerwin.
He wants to know if there's a
way to have a deep-link ID but
still allow people to access the
content URL if they don't
want to install the app
for some reason.
So the question is, is there a
way to have a deep-link ID but
still allow people to access the
content URL if they don't
want to install the app
for some reason?
GUS CLASS: OK, so you have
a deep-link ID, but you--
CHIRAG SHAH: So that won't work
right now, but that is
really good feedback, and that's
something I'll take
back to the appropriate teams.
MALE SPEAKER: So another
question, Gus.
I was a little concerned you
showed your best people and
you didn't have your friendly
GDL producer
listed in that top five.
How does Google+ determine that
affinity of who gets in
that top five?
And what do I need to do to
get in that top five?
GUS CLASS: So I don't have this
specific information here.
It is calculated by Google
based on the available
information that Google has and
the interactions that you
have on Google+.
So be a very friendly person
and do all the great things
that would make you a close
friend of mine, and then you
would appear in my best
friends list.
MALE SPEAKER: Over on YouTube,
there was another question.
Chirag, how does somebody
get such an
awesome shirt as yours?
They want to get this
Google API shirt.
And do you have multiple,
and can you give
some of those away?
CHIRAG SHAH: This is actually
a limited edition, and we no
longer make these
type of shirts.
MALE SPEAKER: Was the
shirt deprecated?
CHIRAG SHAH: Yes.
GUS CLASS: That's a
deprecated shirt.
So I believe Google may also
have a store where you can get
some of the Google-branded
stuff.
I don't know specifically
where that is, though.
CHIRAG SHAH: Yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: Googlestore.com.
GUS CLASS: Googlestore.com,
all right.
Any final questions?
All right, so that's it.
Everything that we've shown
today is well documented on
the Google+ Platform
Developers page,
developers.google.com/plus.
The sample that we showed for
Android is available from the
SDK, and so if you go to the
documentation page that I
showed you earlier, you
can find the sample.
CHIRAG SHAH: And you can also
find all of our samples on
github.com/googleplus, where you
can find samples and all
of our supported languages, and
they also demonstrate the
best practices for integrating
with Google+.
I find this to be the best
resource when trying to learn
a new language, such as Go or
C# because it shows how to
integrate with Google+, but it
also shows how to use that
language and make typical
rest calls.
GUS CLASS: It's really great to
hear that feedback, Chirag,
because when we created the
samples, we tried to create
them as consistent as possible
so that if you're switching
from one language that you're
comfortable in and moving to
another one that you're less
comfortable in, you can
understand what's going on
inside of the sample.
It's worth mentioning
that we also have
additional support materials.
If you go to
developers.google.com/plus and
then go on the left nav,
you can find additional
information about our support
communities such as Stack
Overflow, where we use
the tag Google-Plus.
And also the community page
on Google+, where a lot of
developers are engaging with
each other all the time.
So that's it for today.
Chirag, thank you so
much for coming in.
It's great to have an Android
expert on here.
CHIRAG SHAH: Thank you for
having me on, Gus.
GUS CLASS: All right, so until
next week, stay around and be
sure to watch as we have future
episodes of "Google+
Developers Live."